foreign
let's go to Connor in Baltimore hey
Connor welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey Dave how's it going better than I
deserve what's up
so basically um I just graduated two
years ago I lived at home throughout
that whole time did the commute thing
saved as much money as I could
um so just a few months ago some things
went on at home and I basically had no
decision but to leave and I've always
wanted to buy because you know I've
obviously know that renting is kind of a
waste for some for some reasons um and I
had really no choice so I have a rent
payment now I have a little bit of debt
um but I'm in a salary position and a
good career ladder and I guess I'm just
kind of wondering overall how I can
posture myself to put myself in the best
position moving forward cool what do you
do for a living
um so I work for the federal government
um and I'm I make sixty three thousand
dollars a year good for you okay cool
what was your degree in
um business technology okay still like
data and that analytics and stuff like
that good for you so you're what 22 23
24 yep 24. okay that's awesome how much
debt do you have
so um I have about three thousand
dollars in credit card debt um and
that's just because I had to move out
like very abruptly
um so I need to furnish stuff and just
like that so I just got like a bed and a
couch and stuff like that and just put
it all on a credit card okay
so right now your your question is if
you should buy right now or stop renting
so so basically
um with the way the rent Market has been
I'm spending way more than I should be
on rent because I really didn't have an
option
um but I'm here for a year so then I
guess I'm just wondering I also have um
like a car payment and I probably bought
more car than I should of a year or two
ago just because I didn't anticipate on
having to pay rent so soon
um so I'm wondering how much of my money
I should be putting in to just kill that
all that debt off with the car and
everything
so I paid 400 a month and I have three
years left on it it's a Toyota Camry
what's the balance on it today
um I think 17 000 left I checked okay
big car payment so I have around 20 000
in debt total all right well uh there's
a couple things we can certainly show
you a system to walk a out of this debt
and then B into a position of an
emergency fund of three to six months of
expenses that's maybe steps one two and
three and then start saving to buy a
home at that point uh yes you do want to
buy a home at some point but uh
you don't want to buy them in the
headspace that you're in right now okay
and if you're going to ever win with
money
there's a phrase that you have said
three times in our conversation that you
have to stop believing and you have to
stop saying it
I didn't have a choice
dude you always have a choice
you needed to leave home I get that but
then you went and bought a bunch of crap
on a credit card uh you could have gone
down to a garage sale somewhere and
picked up a used couch for 50 bucks yeah
you did but you didn't okay so you
always have a choice you could have
bought a car that you could pay cash for
but you didn't
you always have a choice
now so you you could you're no longer a
victim of the marketplace or of your
circumstances you are the uh captain of
your own ship and it's your destiny
marked on the side of that ship and
you're in charge of steering your
destiny things are not going to happen
to you anymore you're going to happen to
things you've got to reset that
narrative because otherwise you're going
to do stupid butt crap the rest of your
life and blame it on I was forced to
yes sir okay makes sense so now we'll
get that out of the way now it's real
easy to do the Tactical stuff that you
need to do because you're obviously a
sharp young guy you've obviously got a
lot on the ball you're making really
good money at 24 years old you know
you've got a little bit of car payment
you got a little bit of credit cards
we'll cut up the credit cards we'll get
you on a budget we're gonna chop up get
rid of that credit card debt first and
we'll knock out the car payment and
anything save for a down payment yes
definitely that sounds great I had one
other question too if you don't mind
sure so I I'm not really super into like
um like all of like the interest rates
and stuff like that and like what the
climate makes for a good time to buy a
home but the reason I didn't really buy
one was because I've just heard everyone
saying you know you see it in the news
the terrible time to buy a terrible time
to buy how do you know when it is a good
time it's actually a great time to buy
so
um because house prices are going to do
nothing but go up for the next five
years but you've got you've got some of
these characters on the news trying to
get someone elected or someone unelected
and they're they have an agenda and
they're so they're trying to use the
economy as a lever point on that
um the interest rates are up the market
has slowed down
um it is a better time to buy now than
it was last year at this time because it
was so white hot you'd been bidding
against 27 people and uh so you know but
let me tell you what a bad time to buy
is when you're broke and not ready which
is right now
right okay you got car payments and
credit cards and uh you know you you
haven't got a plan and you feel
discombobulated when you buy a house in
that environment you're about to get
screwed over yeah Connor I would say I
would worry less about what the Market's
doing right now because yeah you're not
ready I think you've got to work through
a lot of this stuff yourself of course
you know we have the baby stuff like
Dave said get your own Financial house
in order and also work through some of
the stuff that you went through with
your family that sounds like it was
pretty rough
um and that you have a lot of healing to
do from that if you hang online we're
going to get you a copy of own your past
change your future by Dr John deloney
who's on the show and I would really
encourage you to go through that and
take a little bit of time because I feel
like right now I can hear the anxiety in
your voice and I can hear this kind of
franticness and I think it's easy to
point to you know maybe it's because I
need a house or maybe it's because I'm
not doing this in life and I gotta hurry
up and I gotta catch up and it's like I
think that's channeled the wrong
direction right now I think you're
focusing on things that aren't going to
make you feel better in the long run
what's going to make you feel better is
dealing with your past and finding a
spot of peace and then dealing with your
finances the correct way paying off all
your debt saving a three to six month
emergency fund investing for retirement
and buying a house you know do it all in
the right order but right now I think
you got to just take some time to
breathe and kind of reset it's wisdom
Christina that's really that's really
really wise because here's the thing
it's obvious from the story we didn't
dig into it but that this was an
emotionally violent separation for you
uh the way you described it two or three
different sentences and talking about it
so um yeah we all heard that and we hear
that in your voice too and you make much
better decisions from a point of
strength and a point of Peace rather
than a wounded animal
and I've been both in my life at times
and I I I I wounded animals don't make
good decisions
and so uh the healing she's talking
about is really really important and
it'll put you on this steady rhythm of
wisdom and even how you go back and deal
with mom and dad later
you know and you're doing that from a
position of strength rather than uh just
barking and snapping and snarling
and that can happen there really easy
so hang on we'll send you a copy of
John's book and also I will throw in a
copy Total Money Makeover which will
show you exactly what to do with your
money and get things stabilized and walk
you through the baby steps